this is the story of how your safety and
future finances were robbed without you
ever really noticing back in the 70s
everyone was like but there was also the
creation of an energy company called
Exxon they were obsessed with what we
are still obsessed with now innovation
though the oil company Exxon decided to
invest in science scientists hired by
Exxon again Exxon's very own scientists
were the first to present a series of
groundbreaking papers explaining that
burning fossil fuels will influence the
climate as the carbon dioxide released
will cause a greenhouse effect isn't it
ironic don't you think that oil
companies discovered climate change this
happened right in the early 1980s just
as the price of oil was decreasing so
the higher-ups at Exxon chose to ignore
the information and instead focus on
growing the business they did ask the
scientists to keep looking into it in
1982 their own scientists again came
back this time with more thorough
research saying yep it was worse than
they thought
based on what Exxon was planning to do
in regards to fossil fuel extraction
would warm the climate cause sea levels
to rise and increase deadly droughts
humans will suffer effects which will be
indeed catastrophic so the scientists
pitched a major reduction in fossil fuel
combustion an email from Lenny Bernstein
a former employee of Exxon wrote in the
1980's Exxon needed to understand the
potential for concerns about climate
change to lead to regulation of
potential projects they were well ahead
of the rest of the industry in this
awareness if Exxon wanted to be
innovators so bad maybe they would have
taken this moment to diversify the
energy sector invest in alternative
energy sources but instead they decided
to lie to you to me and to your mom it
is now the 1980s and for the first time
an internal memo is released at Exxon
that says they need to start to
emphasize the uncertainty of the
scientific data around climate change
they begin to start going against their
very own science and plant the seed for
what we now know as climate change
denial here is part of an internal memo
from Exxon at the time there is
currently no unambiguous scientific
evidence that the earth is warming if
the earth is on a warming trend we're
not likely to detect it before 1995 one
of the most frustrating parts of this
story is that Exxon
did believe their climate change science
right at this time they started to build
drilling platforms in the ocean a little
bit higher up to deal with the rising
sea levels they predicted they also
started to plan to drill in the Arctic
because as they knew the sea ice in the
Arctic was going to mount in the late
80s the effects of climate change began
to become apparent Time magazine had a
picture of the planet and shackles due
to climate change on their cover as the
scientific impact of burning fossil
fuels became public knowledge at the
time 80 percent of Americans claimed
that climate change was an issue and
accepted that it was caused by the
burning of fossil fuels it was also not
a political issue here is Republican
President George Bush senior on the
campaign trail in 1988 after a year of
severe heat waves killed thousands of
Americans don't say these problems are
too big that it's impossible for an
individual or even a nation as great as
ours to solve the problem of global
warming or the loss of forests or the
deterioration of our oceans my response
is simple it can be done and we must do
it let's not forget all that we've
accomplished all that we've accomplished
since America first concentrated its
attention on preserving the environment
under a Republican administration back
in 1970 this is the time when the oil
companies started to get scared of that
evil regulation from the government so
they started to really jack up their
campaigns to increase climate change
denial they became inventive they
actually created the OP ad that we now
sometimes see in newspapers where it
kind of looks like an article but it's
actually fully a paid advertisement so
this is one of the op ads that they paid
for in the liberal New York Times one of
the brighter hopes with the climate
change debate has to be the benefits
achieved through technology notice how
they used the word debate and notice how
they sort of make it seem like oh
climate change might be a good thing
because we're gonna invent new things to
cope they secretly paid scientists to
promote fake science in an article
called climate change a degree of
uncertainty the first line wrote the
debate on climate change has been long
complex and intense this is of course
not true because the court
to their own science that there wasn't
really a debate at all quite a short
explanation that was really quite simple
it's that the burning of co2 creates a
greenhouse effect that warms the earth
in 1997 Lee Raymond the CEO of Exxon at
the time actually decided that in the
presentation he was going to say that no
in fact according to their science the
earth was cooling this was a full lie
again he did this in a presentation in
1997 more than 20 years after his own
scientists first broke the fact that the
greenhouse effect is real and the name
of his presentation boldly a bold lie
was is the earth warming does burning
fossil fuels cause global warming the
Raymond sucks because he also is the
person who began to make climate change
a political issue Lee Raymond persuaded
George Bush the younger one to go
against his campaign promise and take
carbon dioxide off the list of
pollutants these are one of the first
times that we actually see climate
change become a political issue a side
of left or right and at the time the
Republican Party was under a lot of
pressure from these big oil companies
and they released this memo the
scientific debate is closing against us
but not yet closed there's still a
window of opportunity to challenge the
science later in the memo it reads
should the public come to believe that
the scientific issues around global
warming are settled their views about
global warming will change accordingly
therefore we need to continue to make
the lack of scientific certainty a
primary issue of debate all of this hard
work paid off in 2017 around 90% of
Americans did not know there was a
scientific consensus on global warming
52% of Americans think the threat of
climate change has been exaggerated this
lack of knowledge helped Rex Tillerson
who became the CEO of Exxon after it
merged with Mobil to become Exxon Mobil
to sign a 500 billion dollar deal to
explore for oil in the rapidly thawing
Russian Arctic for this plan he was
awarded the Russian order of friendship
global warming and climate change is
caused by our immense burning of coal
gas and oil for energy
this causes the carbon release to
combine with oxygen in the atmosphere to
produce co2 carbon dioxide which traps
heat that would have been radiated back
out into space due to this the action
heat trapped near earth is equivalent to
the heat from four hundred thousand
bombs the size of what was dropped on
Hiroshima being collected in our
atmosphere every day by 2100 the rising
sea levels will cost the world 14
trillion dollars 9 of the 10 deadliest
heat waves in recorded human history
have occurred since the year 2000 since
the 1970s 60% of the world's wildlife
has been killed if we continue with our
current greenhouse gas emissions by 2070
tropical regions that now get one day a
year of oppressive humid heat will get
between 100 to 250 days per year 100
million trees died in California in the
past 10 years and studies show that by
2050 if temperatures rise the way they
are predicted a quarter of the earth
will experience extreme droughts and
desertification Stephen Hawking gave
humanity a deadline of a century to
leave earth as it may be the only way to
save ourselves and who is going to be
able to afford this may be Lee Raymond
as his retirement package from
ExxonMobil was a mere four hundred
million dollars for his impressive work
of making money for the company at your
expense climate change is real I was
lied to you were lied to your parents
were lied to and these oil companies did
all of this because they were
short-sighted they wanted to make money
for themselves but we need to think
about the future and we as young people
are the ones who are left to kind of
figure out this mess it's not
necessarily our fault this is a huge
injustice all these lies and deceit that
these companies did to the public
consciousness are unfair but we have to
figure out what we do now in our next
video we're gonna talk about hope so one
thing is that a lot of people are
challenging and figuring out how the law
should get involved with these companies
they should technically be sued for what
they did
there's the green New Deal happening in
America what exactly is that what does
that mean for such a large economic
power and we're gonna highlight some of
the amazing innovative ways that science
is now trying to figure out how to clean
up this mess thank you so much for
watching if you can subscribe to this
channel we're gonna release the video in
the next few weeks we just wanted to
make this video because we make our
animated videos on Thursday where we try
and get people interested in science and
understanding a critical thought and
learning about how the world works
around us but there
also these other things going on within
the science community that we need to
talk about and that's what this video
was so we hope that you like it follow
me on Instagram and Twitter
smash out like button hit that subscribe
and we'll see you next week